كما تلاحظ الصوره كما تشاهد الصوره
[ضحك]
يتظاهر الالاف من الفرنسيين اليوم في
العاصمه باريس
[موسيقى]
يتظاهر
نحن الان امام مخرج مصنع
[تصفيق]
نحن الان في اقليمي
احنا استاذ عادل
امام الفنان الكبير وحضرتك ادليت بصوتك
الان
ازي حضرتك
انت فخر البنت المصريه
في ميدان التحرير ومزنوقه زنقه والناس
ملمومه عليك والدنيا حر وحاجه ملزقه ومش
ممكن خلينا نتحدث عن حياتك اليوم ادليت
بصوتك في حاجه ثانيه افضل قبل سيطره
القوات الروسيه على
عده من قريه
[موسيقى]
خاصه
خربطت كل شيء تغير بالكامل الاعلام التي
ترفرف والوجود العسكري المكثف
[موسيقى]
خطير جدا ان تتعامل مع هذه الحيوانات
المفترسه فسياسه التعامل معها تحتاج الى
خبره سنوات لتتمكن من استطراك
[موسيقى]
العربيه التلفزيون ايران
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
البنزين
خلاص فهمنا
شو بده هذا الاراضي الاوكرانيه
نعول هذا
طيبها تحتاج لكميات هائله من المياه وهذا
ما دفع
[موسيقى]